all right let me stay with you
good afternoon everyone it's four
minutes past free i suggest that we
begin
today's meeting
item number one if there are no
objections from your side i propose to
adopt the agenda as it stands
item number two my announcements our
meeting is as usual being web streamed
except for the in camera point on the
agenda
i would like to remind all members that
speakers lists are established by
the chair during the committee meeting
you will be invited to raise your hand
during the agenda item the secretariat
will assist me in compiling the speakers
lists in accordance with the floor
requests
we can then
move on
already to
our inter-parliamentary
committee meeting which will take place
from now till approximately
quarter past
five
good afternoon
dear colleagues i would like to open
this inter-parliamentary committee
meeting and welcome
all the colleagues from the national
parliaments attending this session
remotely
and also welcome the members of the
european parliament
here in the roman brussels
a few technical remarks before we start
our discussions as i just mentioned our
meeting is being web streamed
we have interpretation in english french
german italian danish greek dutch
spanish portuguese swedish czech
hungarian lithuanian latin polish
slovak slovene bulgarian romanian and
creation
parliamentarians from the western balkan
countries and turkey have been invited
to join this meeting so there is also
passive interpretation from bosnian
montenegrin serbian and turkish
as well as finnish but you can speak in
those languages but cannot listen to
interpretation into those languages
finally i would like to stress that the
interpreters as always rely on the
quality of the sound and video of remote
participants in order to get your
message across
and please do be aware that phone
interventions and audio only connections
will not
will not be interpreted
let us now start this into parliamentary
meeting focusing on eu enlargement
policy in the aftermath of russia's
invasion of ukraine
it is a great pleasure to welcome
colleagues from the national parliaments
of our member states the western balkan
countries as well as ukraine georgia and
moldova
and turkey they are all connected
remotely
at this stage i would like to welcome
also our guest the commissioner for
enlargement and neighborhood oliver
vargay
is he already
with us or is he connected he's
connected remotely so a warm welcome to
you dear oliver hey
he will join us with an opening address
online and i would also like to welcome
matshay popovsky the acting director
general of degener who will intervene at
the end of our debate
college i think we can all agree that
this discussion couldn't be more timely
just a few days after a historic
decision to grant candidate status to
ukraine and moldova
and the european perspective to georgia
regrettably no breakthrough on the
opening of membership negotiations with
north macedonia
and also albania
has been achieved
russia's war of aggression against
ukraine has led to a new geopolitical
reality pushing the eu to rethink its
enlargement policy and its geography
it has also reinforced the link between
the neighborhood and the enlargement
policies
the eu membership applications of the
free of the eastern partnership country
should give a new impetus to the
enlargement process
including the continued accession of the
western balkan partners
let me finally mention that the foreign
affairs committee of the european
parliament has started deliberations on
the future of enlargement
and draft recommendations on the new eu
strategy for enlargement will be
discussed
right after this meeting
that's all from my side and i would now
like to give the floor to commissioner
vahed for his introductory remarks
for let's say seven minutes oliver floor
is yours
honorable chair dear david
honorable members
of the european parliament honorable
members of
national parliaments and of course
distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen
over the last days we had important
decisions uh taking the eu's enlargement
policy
back
high on the agenda of the eu
last week
the european council endorsed the
opinions of the european commission
on ukraine
the republic of moldova and georgia's
application for eu membership
all three were given the perspective to
become
eu member states
ukraine and moldova were granted
candidate status
on the understanding
that major reform steps will be taken
georgia will be granted candidate status
once the necessary reforms are done
these are decisions that some perhaps
many
thought unlikely some months ago
but historic times bring about historic
decisions
the three countries
now should make full use of the
opportunities created by these decisions
ukraine moldova and georgia
want to join the european union
they consider the european union and the
eu membership
to be the most important
and most reliable tool for security and
prosperity in the long term
we have treated these applications very
seriously
but not as business as usual
we worked hard and did our outmost
to deliver
an answer to the council who had asked
the commission to prepare these opinions
as a matter of urgency
we prepared the rigorous and robust
assessment
applying the exact same methodology
that we have been using in previous
cases
all three applicants were assessed on
the same criteria
based on their own merits
now with the european perspective
ukraine moldova and georgia are set on a
firm
and
reliable track towards the eu
let me recall that the accession process
remains based on established criteria
and conditions
the so-called copenhagen criteria
these criteria first of all
are political criteria
meaning how the country ensures
democracy the rule of law
protection of human rights and
minorities
second
the economic criteria
to assess whether there is a functioning
market economy capable of resisting
competitive market pressures within the
eu
and third
the so-called aki criteria
meaning the capability of applying our
legislation
the eu law
as is on the ground fully
based on these criteria the three
commission opinions which are now
endorsed by the european leaders
identify key reform areas for ukraine
moldova and georgia
where more efforts will need to be done
so that they can make progress on their
eu path
we'll follow closely their progress and
report regularly on it
the decision on the future steps on the
eu path will continue to be in the hands
of the eu member states
based on the progress of the respective
countries
following the revised methodology
in this changing geopolitical context
when we are tightening our regional
partnerships and cooperation our
priority remains the western balkans
we are committed
more than ever to bring the entire
region
within the european union
it is more important now than ever to
work on that not only fast
but with full commitment and will
by all the institutions
we continue our support to the western
balkans and include them in our eu
mechanisms to mitigate the current
crises
we are integrating the religion into our
food security mechanism
and including it as well is in our gas
common gas procurement system
with our 30 billion euros economic and
investment plan we focus on
strengthening the region's economy
reducing dependency on hydrocarbons for
a sustainable future
building a digital economy for
cybersecure future
and helping ensure there is a future for
the youth of the region
in the whole of the western balance
without proper regional cooperation
be it the berlin process
be it the common regional market
or beat the open balkans initiative
the countries in the region simply
cannot reap the benefits of the economic
investment plan
anyone undermining or blocking regional
cooperation based on eu rules and with
eu participation
undermines the economic and investment
plan and the region region moving
forward as one
a lot of efforts have been invested in
overcoming remaining issues between
bulgaria and north macedonia
we are nearly there
this is now the moment for all actors
to take the final step
i have high hopes
that the intergovernmental conferences
with albanian north macedonia
can be held within a matter of days
the countries have delivered
all that has been asked they're ready
and we should be too
we have now a solution on the table
endorsed by the bulgarian parliament
so all obstacles are overcome
europe must move forward
last week the european council gave it
positive signal regarding the
possibility to give candidate status to
bosnia and herzegovina
but this requires bosnia and herzegovina
to deliver
on a substantial set of reforms
we will assess the implementation of the
14 key priorities set out in our opinion
in order to enable the european
to revert
yes
need to get involved on the ground to
help kosovo
from our side we are ready to give all
the necessary financial technical and
political support to this
process regarding the baby krishna
dialogue
we need kosovo
to be
giving us clear commitments and delivery
turning to serbia
we see that serbia is a very difficult
situation under the current geopolitical
circumstances and challenges
we need to recognize that
the issue of sanctions
is only the symptom of the problem
this is why
we are fully ready to support uh serbia
in aligning itself even further
with the eu's policy
on the war of russia in ukraine
but this should lead us to clear new
commitments from serbia as well
needless to say we need delivery also
from berggrady in the dialogue
montenegro has gone through a period of
democratic transition
but the country is on a good track
we expect the new government to restore
the political and institutional trust
to maintain the cross-party dialogue
and to pave the way to move forward
swiftly on the key pending eu reforms
the next milestone for montenegro is
meeting the interim benchmarks for the
rule of law chapters 23 and 24.
before this
no chapters will be closed
finally with regard to turkey the
session negotiations for eu membership
have been effectively at a standstill
since 2018.
the turkish government has reaffirmed
the strategical goal of eu membership on
numerous occasions
however
regrettably our concerns about the
fundamentals of the accession process
remain unaddressed
the commission contin continues
intensifying engagement with turkey in
the
areas of joint interest and in line with
the guidance of the european council
to conclude
the unity the eu has shown until now has
been our biggest asset
we are stronger together
the historic decisions taken last week
provides a clear vision
it is now the responsibility of all of
us
to turn this vision into reality
there is a lot of work ahead we are all
aware of that and we need to go together
on this thank you
thank you very much commissioner
thank you for your valuable insights and
i guess this was a good
kickoff for our today's
discussion
colleagues i have received in total 36
requests to speak from national
parliaments
and we need to add the requests of
speakers here from the european
parliament
this is
a unique opportunity to exchange the
views not only with the eu member states
parliaments but also with colleagues
from countries aspiring eu membership
both in the western balkans and the
eastern neighborhood
so in order to accommodate all the
requests for the floor
and to ensure an equal treatment of all
colleagues i will have to be
strict with the speaking time
which is up to
one minute and 30 seconds per speaker
and once again
i will have to be strict and one minute
and 30 seconds is not 2 minutes and 30
seconds it's 1 minute and 30 seconds and
a remote meeting makes it difficult for
the chair
at a certain stage to simply have to
turn off the microphone
for the connected colleague
but don't blame the chair i'm only
executing our joint rules to make this
possible
so let's
try and make it work and i once again
really ask for your collegial
cooperation
the first speaker
is from a national parliament i would
like to give the floor to mr alexander
meresco from the verhofna rada
please the floor is yours
uh thank you thank you mr chairman i'll
try to be really quick uh
you know what's going on on the ground
that ukraine is currently outgunned
and outnumbered by russia and the war
russia's waging against ukraine is not
only war against ukraine as such it's a
war against europe russia is trying to
punish us for wanting to become part of
european family to be free not to be
slaves of russia but to be part of
europe and we deserve it because we've
been waging war with russia since 2014
and
it took us two revolutions and one long
war to uh to become a member of the
european union i believe that ukraine
is an asset it has a huge potential for
the european union it shouldn't be
treated as a burden or as a problem and
i also believe that there should be
a sort of a new deal or honest deal
between ukraine and the eu ukraine will
be doing everything it can in under very
difficult circumstances of war but
everything we can to to join eu but we
need help from the european union and
the countries to support us because uh
i believe that um
ukraine deserves to become the eu member
as soon as possible uh i think it can
happen within nearest years
and ukraine ukraine should become an
all-european project because we're a
country which will be ruined by russia
which is in the war but russia
we shouldn't um succumb to putin we
should do everything we can to destroy
his plans and to admit you to the
european union as soon as possible thank
you mr chairman
thank you that was a bit over one and a
half minutes that was a good beginning
i understand that mr
gomez reno from the spanish parliament
miss ariana
mozilla shoshi from the
kosovo assembly
and miss
lima andre kina from the same as in live
when you're not connected so the next on
my list would then be
miss rosalia
biro from the
chamber of deputies from romania
hello
everybody i
i hope that you hear me
we hear you but we can't see you miss
biro
you can see
no we can't see you
i will try to manage it if it's possible
miss biro
try and connect again with the camera
in the meantime
i'll give the next the floor now to mr
titos
kolaczyan from the romanian senate
yes uh
go ahead
yes uh hello
yes
hello thank you so much
david uh your colleagues um
i hope we can hear each other and see
each other thank you very much for this
timely uh inter-parliamentary committee
meeting
uh this is the right uh moment after
indeed a historical uh decision taken by
the european council
while granting the status of candidate
for ukraine and the republic of moldova
if you remember
in february just a few days after the
russian aggression
against ukraine just started on 24th of
february we had a meeting in paris
between the chairs of the foreign
affairs and the defense
committees of the member states of
course with our institutional european
institutional partners i was among those
who asked at that time
to grant as soon as possible this clear
european perspective
now there is a clear decision it's the
right decision uh partially i'm slightly
disappointed about the decision taken as
concern uh
georgia uh but uh this is it uh i hope
that before the end of the year this
status of candidate will be granted also
to georgia one small friendly advice to
our georgia friends i think they should
use also the other channel the council
of europe and the parliamentary assembly
of the council of europe monitoring to
advance in the next months with clear
requirements related to their obligation
upon accession to the council of europe
that will be extremely useful in my
opinion also for the fulfilling the
political
criterias to obtain the status of
candidate my final comment if it's
possible related to the balkans in paris
under the french presidency i also
mentioned the fact that we need to
advance faster also with the process
related to the balkans and turkey
unfortunately somehow we are still
taking prisoners by a bilateral dispute
among one member state and one the
candidate country also this
has a negative impact on another
candidate country which is albania my
only hope and political support is
nevertheless to try to find the
compromise solution that will
allow the advancement faster with the
european process also for the balkans
thank you so much
thank you
that was way beyond two minutes but
we're still at the beginning trying to
practice
mihir gala for the first mep
yeah thank you very much also
commissioner for
uh illustrating where we stand now of
course we all welcome the decision that
has been taken
now as i
rapper on ukraine my question is of
course on this country um the assessment
from the commission that had been taken
was dated for the 31st of december 21 of
course before the war started so fair
enough that was the
the point of reference now
when we assess how to proceed and how to
advance
with ukraine it requires now in the
light of the
destruction
that russia has caused to the country
and the overall situation
um the
uh
assessment that you will be doing uh
hopefully by the end of the year i hear
noises that it might take even longer
as of course to consider the the reality
on the ground so my question is how
would we
uh
together with the ukrainians assess
uh what the most urgent needs are they
may all be in moving targets because we
do not know how long the war will go and
in which direction it will go so which
are your thoughts in this regard how to
now thoroughly assess uh
the
where we stand with regard to ukraine
thank you very much
thank you
next
is miss biro we're going to give her a
second try i'm calling bucharest
no no she's not connected
so ms spiro i'm informed that you're not
connected then i move on to the next
speaker and that would be miss marca
boccevilli
from the georgian parliament
thank you i think
um
i thank the european parliament of its
committee for inviting us to this
inter-parliamentary meeting today
it has been a decade that russia's
aggressive policy in our region does not
let us to escape war and destruction
georgia is the country that repeatedly
experienced russian aggression a number
of times and continues to fight against
occupation and its painful consequences
even today
unfortunately after full-scale invasion
of ukraine has the world realized the
real face of russia
we are being punished only because we
dare to think about our freedom and
sovereignty
on 23rd of june the european council
made a historic decision on opening the
eu membership perspective to ukraine
moldova and georgia this is an important
achievement for associated partners
today we mark 8th anniversary of signing
the association agreement and we have
been always serious about implementation
of this agreement knowing that only
reforms and legal approximation with the
eur key will transform the country and
make it make it compatible with the
european union
the progress we have made during these
eight years is tangible and undeniable
georgia unlike ukraine and moldova is
not yet candidate country but it is
crucial that we are now part of the eu
enlargement policy we will continue the
effective implementation of reforms that
will advance georgia on the path of
european integration and bring us to
closer to our ultimate goal it is
disappointing that the european
parliament's recent assessment on
georgia was largely based on the
misinterpreted facts and in some cases
was utterly unfounded
we are currently living in a very
complex geopolitical environment and
making such mistakes only increases the
vulnerability and does not help us to
directly address these threats they
expect that we expect that european
parliament will better analyze and
carefully assess this situation in
georgia and the european union with this
further decision will help us to unite
the nation around the common european
goals and this is the will of 80 percent
of georgia's population thank you
thank you colleague
next is mr johannes burnos from the
hellenic parliament
dear colleagues i congratulate ukraine
and moldova and i hope georgia will be
next we all understand that the russian
aggression in ukraine has changed
everything
most of us seem to agree on enlargement
the strategic autonomy of the eu
of the urgent need to get serious about
europe's geopolitical standing and the
need to closely coordinate and upgrade
our diplomatic efficacy and defensive
capabilities we have realized how much
we need in europe that is an energetic
and influential force for peace and
stability around its neighborhood that
is able to deter aggression in the
continent and share responsibility when
dealing with crisis at its borders on
the other hand our inability to unblock
the candidacy
path of western balkans especially north
macedonia and albania is not just a
simple failure it undermines our unity
and status
instead of reinforcing ourselves we
leave the door open to intervention by
other powers to see the
to use one member state against another
to block the used common foreign policy
and manipulate it to serve their
interests
the enlargement and integration of the
western balkans
is a step towards peace stability and
growth especially for the balkan region
and all current member states so let us
all rise up to the occasion and assume
our responsibilities thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
mep pizzula what's next
thank you
um all distinguished ladies and
gentlemen of the present uh candidates
and future candidates uh
the enlargement is again the focus after
the russian aggression after it has been
set aside for alongside there are
several reasons for that
because of the reduced absorption
capacity of the eu
due to a serious internal and external
crisis and also because the lack of
good reasons for future
enlargement no matter what the
explanation is we can now conclude that
the enlargement policy is one of the
most successful policies of the eu since
its beginning because this is the
development of democratic values and
greater security on the continent the
latter being the biggest threat
right now the support of ukraine and to
moldova uh from the council is a very
good signal and the perspective for
georgia is equally important at the same
time last
week
decisions
were the beginning of a new
apathy in the western balkans because of
the decision about the bosnian opening
with
the accessions uh talks with albania and
several north macedonia and uh vism
regimes shows that the eu can become an
uh credible
political player and this would also be
supported by the end of the discussions
with montenegro you know
the next two speakers from the national
parliaments uh
zolt nemet from the hungarian national
assembly
sold
hello
dear colleagues
dear david my first question
is
related to you we are very glad to be at
an inter-parliamentary committee with
you again
but we are uh we feel bad that we are
not able to shake your hand we would
love it david
do you
still intend to invite us to strasbourg
or brussels in the near forcible future
this is my first question the second one
uh is relating the enlargement and the
neighborhood policy
uh mr commissioner enlargement and
neighborhood policies
uh have been treated separately until
now it seems now that the policies and
the instruments have to be integrated
also in the near forcible future what do
you think about this and my third
question relates georgia
if the ukrainian and the moldovan
decision was a geopolitical decision as
it was said by you
mr commissioner i think it was
a really important mistake or a
missed opportunity that we have not
treated in the same way georgia because
georgia was the first country who was
the victim
of the russian aggression in 2008 and as
mrs macca boracay said
it is uh
in georgia it had a very very negative
reception and understandably so so
i would like to ask you mr commissioner
that
why
this
differentiation has taken place
is it true that some people suggest that
the geographical position of
georgia is too bad did it play any role
in this development and then do you plan
to
replace
this decision with the more positive one
thank you very much
thank you zolt for your comment and also
as regards your question
believe me zolt i sincerely hope that
for our next inter-parliamentary
committee meeting in autumn
we will be able to finally welcome you
all again in brussels
you can imagine it's much more fun to
share a meeting in physical presence
than with colleagues who are sometimes
connected remotely sometimes not
so once again salt i can't wait
to see and greet you personally after
the summer break at our next meeting in
autumn i will make sure
that covert will not take place in
europe while we're having this ipc
meeting
next on my list is now um
where's the list i need it
um
mr oh gary capelli from croatia please
thank you for
the organization of the meeting today
last week ukraine and moldova were
granted candidacy status we welcome that
croatia in its uh work through the eu
institution has been continuously
advocating
we know
that uh it was in particular the
existing of the prime minister of
croatia and the government that uh
advocated that we believe that uh
georgia will soon achieve the same
result in this very challenging times
for eu the enlargement policy had to
adapt to certain circumstances however i
want to emphasize how important is is to
keep in focus also the countries of what
is called western balkans in particular
in within the security mechanism which
we
mentioned so much at the beginning of
this conference today the lack of
european perspective in these countries
which have uh
have held a candidate status for some 17
years that would mean that some other
perspectives will prevail in this if you
allow me to call it in this inner
courtyard of eu i believe that we as
member states
don't have
an interest in
such matter happening
so i
welcome
the
lifting cavito uh regard north macedonia
i hope that they as well as albania will
still
start negotiating thank you
thank you mr cappelli and colleagues to
make things even more complicated i've
been informed that the clock taking the
time of speakers is no longer
functioning
so we're going to have to do this with
our own
stopwatch
next is mep david guetta please
mr ghetto
yes i would just like to make a give a
reminder to member states to those
countries with the statute of candidates
and countries aspiring to have that
status the european union today can no
longer consider any enlargement without
undertaking a profound reform of its
institutions
and even a reinvention of its
institutions i would say today the
emergency
is to open up the discussion between
member states and countries
uh
aspiring to becoming candidates
it's not about
making wishes about accelerating
the accession process please remind the
tough i'm sorry i have to remind you of
this tough reality but i had to thank
you
thank you david ghetto
oh sorry
see ya
i was with my teenage daughters all
weekend and
your nephew is even more famous than you
are at least among german teenagers
um
mark de mesa is the next speaker from
the belgian senate
excuse me
[Music]
sorry i was lost in translation
um
good afternoon colleagues
i would like to say two things the title
of our meeting refers to the aftermath
of russia's aggression
so the aftermath uh but the problem is
that we're not yet in the aftermath the
war is still ongoing and has been since
2014
so we need to
as the european union putin believes
that our unity isn't going to continue
we
are a democracy
putin doesn't have any electoral
issues to worry about but we do and we
need to make sure that we can sustain
this in a longer term that's what
worries me so it's very important for
our ukrainian friends to be able to end
this conflict quickly if we can give
them the opportunity
to end the war quickly we need to
provide to them what they need
and also to not give them conflicting
signals
we are being told by some member states
that we mustn't humiliate putin
another point is that membership of the
union goes back to the starting point of
our european union which is uh the
ability of all european citizens to live
in free democratic states
regarding
ukraine
you need to look at the journey that
they have already made in the context of
the uh
association treaty
at the same
time
this will take some time because we
mustn't compromise the
implementation of the copenhagen
agreement and so the timing and the
speed of implementation is going to
depend on
our partners as well
we are aware of what putin's foreign
policy is how he sees europe how he sees
the integration of western balkan
countries which he will certainly try to
go against so i hope we have learned
some lessons from this
is mr nicola lavrinovic from bosnia and
herzegovina
mr lavery
sisters
thank you
the
russian invasion into ukraine has placed
at the center of the debate the
enlargement of the union's borders
portuguese parliament has had the
opportunity some days before the
european council
to um
support overwhelmingly
the candidate stated to ukrainian it's a
truly historic moment for the future of
the union
a moment which will find a new order
based upon a political commitment but
also on a security commitment the
finance has become
a predominant issue in this new
strategic scenario but we should always
keep on defending democracy and human
rights which are the fundamental rights
of the
rights that each one of the potential
members of the eu will have to show that
it complies with so as to be a member of
our family
we should be at the front line to the
found
the granting of the candidate status to
these countries
it also lie
to call to attention to
some caution
um for the
implementation of the copenhagen
criteria which are into
the um credibility um and the continuity
of these accession countries we will
certainly willing to uh provide all
supports in the ukraine
um so to wish that it will uh soon
restore um
its tranquility and this is our favorite
wish from portugal so that it can fully
uh comply with the requirements to be
part of this big european family thank
you
thank you thomas fights from the
european parliament please
thank you chair um yes first of all
thanks to all the colleagues on to
participate on this meeting today very
important to hear your voices uh on
ukraine and moldova we have to be aware
that granting candidate status is done
out of solidarity out of support for
your struggles out of respect uh of how
you are defending your country your
values and our values uh it's not based
on a merit-based process as we're having
it on the balkans but i still stand
straight to back this decision i'm happy
that we took it when it comes to balkans
what the effect of this decision while
not really proceeding with the balkan
area western balkan area is that we are
losing even more credibility than we
have lost already in the balkans and
especially when it comes to bosnia well
i have understanding that we may wait
until the elections to grant bosnia
candidate status ship but the same
arguments as for moldova and as for
ukraine may also count for bosnia we're
having with the republican rubska and mr
dodic a leadership that is in close
alliance with mr lavrov and mr putin
which is co-financed and financing
partly statehood or semi-statehood with
russian money and which is clearly in
contact and involved into a russian
strategy and i do really not think that
we should wait until the first bullet
flies until we take the needed decisions
to also realize that this is has a
geostrategical dimension as well and
it's the very same
strategical dimension as we have with
moldova and russia and last but not
least the call to our very own member
states please to all the non non uh
accepting and non uh recognizing
countries to kosovo please reconsider
your position we urgently need your
consent also to move on with something
like visa liberalization on kosovo we
got to do our homeworks within european
union before or let's say at the same
time as we demand progress from
candidate status countries
thank you
the next two speakers from the national
parliaments i will give the floor first
to mr piero fascino from the italian
chamber of deputies
thank you mr chairman
and thank you very much for this very
appropriate
meeting moment we're all glad that the
european
council has granted the ukraine the um
via the um candidate status in in
perspective
to george and i congratulate with
colleague marisk when i salute him i'd
like to concentrate on the balkan though
in fact the balkan issue is becoming
extremely urgent 27 years have elapsed
since the time agreements and
19 years from this the saloniki council
and so this is a very long amount of
time and the result of such a time lapse
being so long is that frustration in the
public opinion in the balkans has grown
the invasiveness of china russia turkey
emirate in the balkans has grown and the
balkan countries that should carry out
the reforms as the european union slowed
down they also slowed down in parallel
we haven't obtained any positive result
you know waiting 20 years to let the
balkans
join the eu so what i say is that it's
time to change these things an
ambassador from the balkan
area a few days ago told me should we
wait for russia to invade us before the
euro european union considers us members
of the family now i believe that these
words have got to sound as an alarm
bell so it's time we uh speed up and the
european parliament concluded in a
document saying accelerating the
negotiations well this actual
acceleration has got to be concrete can
just be a statement
and nothing more as for macedonia the
proposal of the french
presidency is that
the uh commitment of macedonia to modify
their constitution is an important
element to
open up the negotiations but the french
proposal does not imply that until the
constitution is
amended negotiations with the machida
macedonia cannot be opened so let's not
do any mistakes we have to be timely
give a sign in sign of timeliness and
effective political integration of the
balkans we have no more time
is pavel fisher from
the czech senate
thank you so much uh mr chair
very happy to take part in this
important
debate
at this very moment i will have one
question to our friends from western
vulcans who are online or who are
participating here today
because among the conclusions of this
european council we read under the
number 15
that in the conclusions
european
council calls
for
acceleration of the accession process
and my colleague from italy spoke about
already my question mark is how do you
in western balkans imagine that this
acceleration
should be realized
and now my second point and final one is
that i would like to react to the
first
introductory remarks by oliver farhey
the commissioner on neighborhood and
enlargement
a member of the commission which because
to be
geopolitical commissioner you have our
full support because you
i try to quote you said
commission will help to align with eu
policy on the war with russia
and you spoke about serbia i think that
the
relationship of eu with russia
and china is very conflictual and we
will help
serbia to deliver also on this but the
choice is theirs and we have to allow it
that buying weaponry from russia or
china might be extremely dangerous thank
you
thank you pavel fisher
miss von frisco is next please
thank you chair grazie president
and all the colleagues from the national
parliaments who
are here today to celebrate the unity of
the european union in spite of all the
diversities we represent
now it is our desire to stay united and
to stand by ukraine and this dramatic
moment of invasion
from russia and stay
and flank them continuing to provide
military economic and any other type of
resource for the end to be halted to be
stopped as soon as possible the
commissioner has underlined that the
balkans are looking ahead and looking
for new opportunities to cooperate and
to develop further contact and
relationship within a well-deserved
european and atlantic perspective now as
an example i would like to refer to
albania since january the first it is
part of the safety security council of
the united nations and therefore can
make decisions on the most outstanding
issues worldwide beat conflicts their
consequences on famine
energy
the nuclear threat terrorism and so on
so at this point i
would like to mention the words of the
albanian ambassador of heritage at the
um
united nations palace on the western
balkans that he exhausts as a rapidly
developing country a region that does
not forgets its own history but is not
hostage to its past so the deliberate
acceleration by the european council is
therefore a moral obligation for us and
europe cannot waste time
thank you
yeah
miss bronfisco i have good news
apparently the clock is back
so um
please keep an eye on the one and a half
minute
proposal
next speaker on my list from the
national parliaments is mr
harris georgiadas from the house of
representatives in cyprus
thank you
dear colleagues uh ukraine's application
at a time when it is
waging a struggle for its freedom and
independence against the brutal
authoritarian
regime russia's prudence russia
and the granting of
of of the candidate status represents a
triumph for european integration
and the cases of moldova and georgia
carry an equally significant symbolism
it is such countries which
demonstrate real commitment to european
liberal democracy to european values and
principles which deserve the right to
membership and i would also like to
encourage the other african states from
the western balkans to maintain their
commitment and effort
on the other hand this cannot be said of
countries which fail to respect
international law which violate human
rights and which do not respect the
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity of of their neighbors of eu
member states thank you mr sherman
thank you
next is mr tom marsh valashek from the
slovak national council
many thanks david and i apologize for
the informal getup but it's unbelievably
hot in slovakia
um
colleagues it isn't obviously over the
war but it's not too early to start
drawing some early lessons i mean to me
the most important lesson
is that we gain absolutely nothing as
europeans by
from denying countries a desire
membership
the right to apply and leaving them in a
gray zone
this is not to say obviously that all of
the countries that wish to join will
also qualify in the end but it does mean
that those who wish to join
those that are in europe and clearly
live and die by our european ideals
should never be told no out of the fear
of angering russia because that attitude
gains us nothing vladimir putin i'm
afraid will do as he pleases he is
determined to restore the zone of
influence that includes the former
soviet satellites and he will try to
pursue that goal including through use
of force irrespective of what we do and
say we don't have the power to change
his mind but we do have the power to
deny him success
um and one of the most important ways is
of course by
binding countries and willing countries
such as ukraine close to the eu and
eventually into the eu not just the same
street but into the same house we now
have a mountain of evidence that
accession works not perfectly but a vast
majority of countries that have joined
have become more prosperous more
democratic and therefore more immune to
russian shenanigans
my last point
i listened carefully to chancellor
schultz's warning that enlargements have
increased the need for reform and i
agree
but i warned that that mustn't become an
excuse for us not to advance ukraine's
and moldova's memberships now that we
have done the right thing and granted
them a candidate status the absence of
reform including in the way we make
decisions that's our problem our
challenge not theirs so let's get on
with it thanks david
thank you thomas
next is
for
the european parliament kingagal
thank you chair
i'm happy that the enlargement got a new
impetus with the decision last week
taken and thanks to commissioner varga
to his clean commitment towards
enlargement uh what
he expressed in his intervention in the
beginning
i think it was a very important symbolic
decision to give the candidates ages
ukraine and moldova and it
it will help the european perspective
these countries but it is also very
important to remain coherent in decision
taking and cred out to keep our
credibility therefore i regret that uh
georgia as well as bosnia herzegovina we
know were not granted uh the same status
this time
i want to underline as it was underlined
several times today but it's it we have
to to press on this that it is more
important than ever to keep our
credibility and reliability towards the
western balkans
it is in the interest of us
to
that uh the security uh of eu and the
stability of eu is linked strongly to
the security and stability of the
western balkans and we have to encourage
these countries because what we see and
feel now is a disappointment and
discouragement from their side so
therefore i underlined that we have to
speed up negotiations and open up new
chapters with serbia and montenegro and
open negotiations with north macedonia
and albania give the candidate status to
bosniatzagovina and grant visa
liberalization to kosovo thank you chair
thank you kinga
next is mr branimir gavos denovich from
the scorpion and montenegro
thank you good morning distinguished
members of the european parliament and
uh other parliamentarians i would like
to convey
our best regards from uh mr shalanovich
and we believe that uh
the situation ukraine is pointing to the
importance
of uh the
uh federal membership of the western
balkan countries in the eu
and the uh process should be accelerated
and we have foreign policy ambitions
which have been set aside because of uh
priorities related to internal
consolidation uh the message sent by
mep's
is quite clear that western balkan
countries should be a part of the eu we
are
getting closer to the eu the only uh uh
alternative that is acceptable for
montenegro is full membership in the eu
next year next week sorry uh we will uh
devote a session our parliamentary
session to the report of uh the u.n and
the european parliament and uh with your
participation and mr tony pizzula
and uh
we will have an opportunity to talk
about the eu future of montenegro so
we're looking forward to and asking you
to uh join us
online
to talk with you and your associates and
to see whether you are available
montenegro is fully aligned
with uh
foreign and security policy of the eu we
are supporting the ukraine its
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and i would like to welcome
uh
the decision of the eu to grant uh
uh candidate status to ukraine and
moldova
but at the same time you should not put
on hold
uh countries with the western balkans
i would like to invite the eu and appeal
to the eu to take this opportunity and
use this situation to uh
have western balkans uh uh to uh
continue
its pass
thank you very much and uh we'll be in
touch thank you very much
thank you
next is
mr antonio miloski from the republic of
north macedonia
he's not connected then i can now give
the floor to
miss biro from romania who i have been
informed is now connected
miss biro
yes mr claire
uh i am very um
i will talk without camera unfortunately
the connection uh is not very good
um
so congratulations for moldova and
ukraine and the european perspective of
georgia romania has been and remain a
consistent and
active supporter of eu enlightenment
process the russian
military aggression against ukraine has
once again highlighted that
we need a strength eu
political influence both at the level of
its neighbors and on the global stage
we welcome the full alignment with the
decision of the european union in the
field of the common foreign and security
policy
of many western balkan partners and
reiterate our core and other partners in
the region to move forward in this
process our support is based not only on
the belief that these countries belong
to the greater european family but also
on the reality of the progress they have
made in the reform process
uh a session of the european union is
not a short-term goal unfortunately but
the aspiring state must benefit from the
optional framework for the reform
process
romania strongly support the need for a
visionary political gesture in line with
the commitment of the
aspirating states
and we support a clear engagement
process we need to encourage the western
states we need a strong political will
and an efficient strategy thank you
thank you miss spiro now i give the
floor to andreas kabilius from the
european parliament
well thanks a lot sir
very briefly you know definitely also
congratulations to
our friends
in ukraine and in moldova
for getting
recent decisions
but also i'd like to congratulate eu
the decision makers that
for me it looks like the eu is coming
back to
understand that enlargement policy
really is of a huge geopolitical
significance
so i would not agree with those who are
saying that um candidate status given to
ukraine and moldova is just a symbolic
guest it's
it's some kind of you know humanitarian
aid
so this is not based on a merit-based
approach not at all i think that you
know the difference which we see is
coming from
changes inside of eu
mentality and understanding
and i hope that it will mean that
the previous very popular slogan that
there is lack of appetite for
enlargement will be changed into you
know a new slogan hungary for
enlargement he needs to have
such an ambition how to expand the area
of democracy development and prosperity
on european continent and i would
suggest really to look into possibility
to create from parliamentarians you know
something like alliance for enlargement
to mobilize permanently to mobilize
political will on eu side for
enlargement policy and also for neededtv
institutional reforms and also for you
know mobilization of political will on
applicant countries to go uh for reforms
that's our common agenda and we need to
do and we need to mobilize ourselves in
order to achieve our goals
thank you andreas
the next speaker is from serbia miss
rivera coverage
please
thank you
um distinguished chair uh dear
colleagues on behalf of the national
assembly of the republic of serbia and
its committee for european integration i
would like really to thank you for the
invitation to this meeting
the eu accession process for membership
represents the strategic commitment and
the major foreign policy priority for
the republic of serbia
and therefore the country continues to
reaffirm its commitment to the process
of integration into the european union
as well as to the acceptance of european
values and principles
before exceeding the eu serbia will
continue to gradually align its foreign
and security policy with the eu in order
to have it fully aligned on the point of
conclusion of negotiations
we regret most sincerely all the
developments
in eastern europe we are facing and we
see and feel the loss of
every life of every man in
ukraine as a true tragedy
guided by the principles on which its
foreign policy is based the republic of
serbia considers the violation of the
territorial integrity of any country
including ukraine to be wrong
and
what is most important i would like to
point out that we are following very
closely internal developments in the
european union we are concerned about
the same problems that member states are
facing um both economically and
externally
and
we hope that the european union will
successfully tackle the issues it is
facing
that the enlargement policy will not be
brought into question thank you for your
attention
thank you avira kovach for your
statement next is mr adrian bautel or
botel from moldova
thank you mr chairman mr commissioner
distinguished parliamentarians and dear
friends
first of all thank you for the
solidarity and support shown in the
request of moldova for the candidate
status and european perspective
alongside ukraine and georgia in these
times of war and crisis
all we want is to be part of the free
world and this
candidate status is of outmost important
for us
european integration for the republic of
moldova is the process of internal
transformation and improving economy
ensuring better living conditions for
the citizens of the republic of moldova
in the first place already next in the
next weeks the government will put
together a plan on implementing
commissions recommendations and will
adjust its institutional settings to
improve the coordination of eu-related
reforms and eu-related agenda
we look forward for a bigger or
increased support from the eu and member
state in accelerating implementation of
the eu reforms in the current situation
bigger support for the eu integration of
moldova means more resilience in the
face of the crisis caused by russian
invasion of ukraine it means bigger
capacity for moldova to stay solider
with ukraine and continue offering
humanitarian support and support for the
refugees that comes to the republic of
moldova and it means a bigger hope for
the moldovan citizens in a safer and
more secure day of tomorrow
we really looking forward working even
closer with all of you at the european
parliament at the national with the
national parliaments and of course in
this troubling times
our associated trio of moldova georgia
and ukraine should stick together should
be solider and strong thank you very
much
thank you for the european parliament
nacho sanchez amore please
gracias david
thank you david the operation to offer
the wish from the eastern countries to
be part of the european union is a
political operation operation which
geopolitical reasons have to do with the
war none of the countries fulfill the
conditions and unless
there was a war we wouldn't be talking
about this this is why we don't
understand why we should have a
differentiated treatment to georgia one
thing is to give out a political signal
and something else is to send the
questionnaire which is already part of a
formal proceeding in that time what was
geopolitical reasons for just one of the
candidates or neighbors georgia becomes
a
democratic conditionality process and we
don't really understand why it is clear
that we are not very happy with what's
going on in georgia in the past
year but if
this is an operation with a geopolitical
meaning we cannot divide the uh trio
with a different uh conditions for once
or for for the different countries if as
the commission and the council said we
are very concerned for the political
division in the country my fear is that
whatever the reasons that we have to
give a different treatment for georgia
those reasons will not be the same that
we'll be having in the domestic
uh policy in georgia and this will
deepen the polarization we are now
criticizing this is why we need to solve
this as soon as possible and place
georgia at the same status as ukraine
and moldavia as soon as possible and
then we'll start negotiations and then
we will apply to georgia our critics to
what the parliament is doing in the last
year but dividing the three countries
right now is a political mistake with
great consequences for georgia thank you
thank you natural
next is miss ventis lava lubinova from
the bulgarian national assembly
i've been informed that you have camera
problems if you speak without camera
it's english only and it would not be
interpreted
please
hello
hello
uh bulgaria has
always been one of the strongest
supporters of enlargement
even when the process was not so popular
for my country enlargement is the best
opportunity
the together augment and consolidate the
space of freedom democracy
peace
good neighborliness and prosperity of
the european continent
this cause is even more important today
because of russia's brutal aggression
against ukraine
i welcome the decision of the european
council to grant status to ukraine and
moldova
i am sure
that we will all continue to work to
make this happen for georgia as well
which is also my personal cause
i would like to say a few words about
the western balkans where the
geopolitical situation
it is still different from the our
eastern partners
i deeply believe that each country
without exception each of the six
countries must move more decisively
towards the european union
each with its own characteristics and
achievements
also alignment with the common foreign
and security policy is a key indicator
of the level of perception and respect
for european values
it is time to thank the french
presidency the commission
and the member states for their efforts
to make the republic of northern
macedonia closer to the start of
negotiation
i realized that this process was not
easy it's not easy at all especially for
my country i believe that now it's the
time for courage and strong
political will on the part of the
northern macedonia for both decision
for both decisions
our closest neighbor to move forward to
our common future
within the european union courage
dear friends
we will be with you all the way thank
you
thank you
next speaker
is for
the
european parliament dragos to raku
thank you david um
i'll move straight to questions
commissioner verily um
i'll read some of the conditions that
both ukraine and moldova have to fulfill
until the end of the year for the next
round of assessment on the commission's
side
fight corruption increased capacity uh
complete reform
the
oligarchization
by eliminating excessive influence my
question is um clearly there will need
to be some sort of a translation into
more concrete deliverables more tangible
and measurable
so how will you work with the two
countries now uh to translate again
these conditions into a concrete plan
and and what is the calendar for that
second question according to the new
methodology uh the member states are due
to have a more
increased um inclusive uh
role
in the
assessment um how will that happen
how will you involve the member states
more in working with ukraine and moldova
on their paths that they're just
starting thank you
thank you dragosh
i am now calling the portuguese assembly
mr george seguro sanchez
chair
of the committee commissioner dear
participants of the european parliament
and national
a
parliaments
word of greetings to our guests welcome
first of all i'd like to express the
position that you should have in this
massa
a position of union clear and
transparent which do not end any
difficulties to the right situation in
ukraine the strengths of the eu has been
precisely its joint action in this war
to defend the democratic values in this
framework i'd like to congratulate the
commission for the proposal and the
recent decision to advance decisively in
accepting
the memberships of ukraine moldova and
georgia
but the granting of these statues should
not be done with any mental reservation
neither to generate expectations or
frustrations and the eu has to assume
simultaneous that it needs to reflect
upon its institutional
architecture and at the same time
strengthen the need to ensure a very
clear commitment of continuity of the
financial humanitarian support to
ukraine towards its um needed recovery
we've deemed very important the current
situation ukraine should strengthen the
needs to reflect
on other common policies in the use such
as energy policies and
energy supply um policies um promoting
renewable energies with
defend consensus and we defend an urgent
action
in
um
the compliance of these
member countries to the conditions for
accession thank you
he from the national council of slovakia
dear chairman dear friends
of course it's a pleasure that our
neighbor ukraine received a status of
candidate on other side the country is
bleeding
and we have an european union a rule
that
we can accept only a country without any
border disputes
and in this case
we in fact if we think about it really
leave georgia
moldova and
ukraine
in faith in hands of kgb criminal from
kremlin because all these three
countries have
border disputes and if we stick to this
rule
all the invitations all the nice
gestures are less words
by the way i would use my time to appeal
on all colleagues parliamentarians they
should press to the governments that
it's nice to
participate in a meeting and give
invitation but ukraine needs weapons
weapons and weapons because only
victorious ukraine can be
member of eu and that's why it's our
duty not only to invite but also to do
the most
actual and most
positive thing we can do for them by the
way we should avoid any fifth column any
agent of putin in european union and it
is also the case of western balkan there
is no interest in country that look to
kremlin as a other truth thank
you thank you
next speaker here in the european
parliament is mr kurtzos
thank you german
i would like to salute the decision of
the commissioner in charge of the uh
enlargement who said that historic
moments call for historic decisions but
may add to that that historic decisions
namely in favor of enlargement and the
inclusion of ukraine and moldova and
later georgia also impose efforts of
historic dimensions this is why i
believe that both at the military level
and
when it comes to financial aid
we're not helping ukraine
as much as we should moreover would like
to ask the commissioner
how
he thinks of approaching the ukrainian
issue because the uh normal process for
enlargement i do not believe could be
implemented
since it is uh easy to foresee that in
the years to come
russia
will be uh occupying a considerable part
of your current territory there will be
a kind of war situation
so i fully agree with my call from
ukraine as to the fact of the issue
being not just the aggression by uh
russia against the ukraine it's an
aggression against the europe and the
european security system which is why i
believe
that serbia and turkey need to be
keeping a greater distance from putting
in his policies
this is a time for them to prove to us
that are in favor of their european
perspective thank you
thank you
next is mr alessandro
gilgiovina
dear colleagues
good afternoon to all of you first of
all i would like to express my
solidarity to the ukrainian people
the uh
granting candidate status to ukraine is
an important political gesture we know
that the time will be quite long and
let's underline it
as for the moment being it is a
political gesture at the time being this
is a political act and a very important
one in the balkans we have to speed up
and very briefly i believe we have to
avoid that those countries
look
eastward due to the uncertainties of the
european union and we know that looking
eastwards means also in economical
respect but also with respect to russia
and china
now the european union should be
a partner fostering dialogue in this
very difficult moment
i feel sorry
thinking that the european union has
been overtaken as an institutional
element that has been even surpassed by
turkey and by erdogan
i believe that it is up to us it is up
to the european union to place itself
at the center of the history and resume
once again its role as a an element or
as a
uh
some a as a
um
something as an element that can lead
the way towards peace and therefore make
it possible for europe to take it on its
role in the world
from the republic of moldova
hello do you hear me
miss gammon we can hear you but it would
be even nicer if we could see you would
you like to turn your camera on
yeah sure
one second
excellent go ahead
thank you chair mcallister dear
colleagues dear friends aldo is a small
country that just became a few days ago
a country with great hope and reach of a
european future and this historic
decision to grant moldova and ukraine
the eu candidate status
is a crucial turn for our people that
for sure will bring more democracy
stability security and peace for us but
for the whole european community as well
the european parliament demonstrated
that has a strong voice and political
will
advocating for moldova as a country that
can bring value to the enlargement
process
and i believe that we can grow into a
resilient democratic and prosperous
country
we will definitely remain a responsible
and committed partner and work with even
more dedication to pursue this european
country project
the project that should and will join
the efforts of our entire society i mean
the authorities the civil society
business community and of course our
huge and great moldovan diaspora
we will complete the essential steps of
our justice reform fight against
corruption
the protection of human rights the
equality and safety of all our citizens
and i strongly believe that our future
the future of the republic of moldova is
in the european union thank you ever so
much
thank you miss gammon
next is mr coleman brenner from hungary
[Music]
now we have the image now you can see me
is that right yes so thank you very much
uh mr uh chairman i would like to
continue in my german native language
dear colleagues uh in this new
historical epoch
following the aggression war of putin's
russia against ukraine it is very
important that the european union
would send very clear
signals and that is why
i very much welcome the decision of the
european union with respect to
ukraine and moldova but i would also
like to see the same signal
as well in the case of
bosnia-herzegovina as also with
georgia many sunday speeches
of goodwill we
pledge that the european union is a
community of values and that is why it's
important to send
unequivocal signals in western balkan in
terms which
uh worked
against the influence of countries like
russia and china and to convince them
those countries that on
that is very important on the european
continent to secure prosperity and
freedom and the european fundamental
rights and as a
last thought as a member of the german
minority
uh in hungary i would also like to
emphasize the rights of minority under
the copenhagen criteria our linguistic
and cultural diversity should also be
safeguarded in i'll protect it in the
new member states thank you very much
bye track
next speaker is very much
do you like us from the hellenic
parliament
hello from athens i would like to salute
my friend chair mccallister the friend
jeff fasino
and all the colleagues we meet amidst a
war a war within europe which renders
even more timely the message of the
visionaries and the founding fathers of
the eu
for a political unification of europe
but also it makes urgent the need not to
allow to any revisionist power to put in
doubt the different treaties and the
borders causing different problems in
other territories and causing turmoil
now when it comes to the enlargement
process for these three countries greece
for sure supports a very close
partnership
according to the different accession
agreements signed under the hellenic
presidency in 2014 but we must also
focus on two things first
this enlargement depends on the efforts
made by each country separately and
second we must also highlight that along
with this enlargement we must pay
attention to the other countries
which for the last time period negotiate
have negotiating procedures with the eu
i'm talking about western balkans
where there we must all focus on in
order to be able to assist everybody
accelerate when it comes to the european
integration let us all complete the
vision for a big
united european family thank you so much
for your attention i wish you all the
best from athens thank you
thank you if yaristo
mr haki abazi from
the kosovo assembly is next
mr abbasi is not connected then i give
the floor to
mr nicolas
zamcharatza from
georgia hello
um it is with mixed feelings that i'm uh
addressing you today
on the one hand we are very happy that
the european council took a decision on
uh giving membership perspective to
georgia ukraine and moldova that we
could not even have dreamt of uh six
months ago
on the other hand we are disappointed by
differentiating between the
associated trio and it is especially
this uh disappointing that the
conditions that are set for the three
countries uh are
mostly the same conditions at almost 90
percent um and
this is even more
lex logical explanation why
georgia has to implement the conditions
first and then get status whereas
ukraine and moldova got the status with
the conditions we hope that the
explanation given by president macron
that it's all about uh jio's strategic
location
is uh will not uh hold true because
otherwise uh then it means that
the doors for georgia are uh shot um on
the other hand
i would like to also uh stress that the
conditions that we need to implement
some of them are
very concrete and we welcome that and we
will of course implement them but some
of them
are vague and
cannot be really measured so
we would like to have more clarity on
those conditions
that
that might be
read differently and this is something
that we need to work
together with you in order to advance
george's membership path and in six
months to reconsider this decision thank
you very much
thank you colleague
if i'm informed correctly we are facing
the last four speakers
all from the national parliaments
i now would like to give the floor to mr
marios
matijaitis from lithuania
so he's not connected then i'm calling
mr anastasios
hatsey
from the greek parliament
is our greek
friend connected
if that is not the case i am calling
miss stefania craxy from the italian
parliament
well that was an empty room
formed is now connected
mr haki abbasi will give it a second try
mr abbasi we hear you and now we would
like to now we see you and now we would
like to hear you
no we can't hear you
microphone
unmute mute
i'm sorry we can't hear you but we can
see you
hmm
now now whatever you did that was good
please go ahead
please
no no no no
say something
go ahead kosovo can you hear me now yes
go ahead
perfect thank you chair and i'm sorry
about that
um just to reiterate some of the
uh speakers were very happy about
ukraine and moldova there is no more
critical historical time to move swiftly
with great leadership from the eu
we won the same for georgia obviously
coming from western balkans
uh that needs to be moving ahead so i
fully agree with chair facino and
mp weights and uh to the answer to the
question on mr powell fisher yes we need
to be bold and call for alignment of the
uh foreign policies and defense and
security policies for all the members
and aspiring members
kosovo is ready has put the sanction has
passed the resolution in support of
ukraine is ready to move forward and we
fully believe not only on the right of
the
uh visa liberalization but also on the
membership of the council of europe as
well
so my question a critical question is to
mr vargheli what kind of roadmap we're
talking when european commission in 2008
18 has confirmed that kosovo has
fulfilled all the criterias double of
other countries who have entered the
visa liberalization process so please
please let's review fundamentally the
position of the leadership and move in
the bold ways in order to close all the
gaps for third actors in the european
continent and kosovo kosovo government
and kosovo institutions are absolutely
ready to meet
and
work pragmatically as in the case of the
energy
agreement with serbia but also on other
aspects in order to close any type of
vulnerability for the european continent
that it's coming as a threat of the
third actors especially from russia and
its proxies in the continent
thank you
i'm asking
the secretariat is anybody else from the
national parliaments
connected
this is crazy within three minutes
no
um
look we're at the end of our speaking
list and we can't wait for further
colleagues to
go back
i would then conclude today's speakers
list
and
would like to call
the genia
commissioner hey and later on mate
popovsky have been
listening carefully to all the comments
made by our colleagues from the national
parliament in the european parliament
and matriapovsky it's up to you now to
try and
answer as many questions as possible and
also on the many comments you've heard
so i'll give the floor to you we are
quite good in time if you can try and
sum it up in
15 minutes that would be very helpful
mache
mache
mache we can see you but we can't hear
you
once again can you hear me now yes now
we can thanks i'm sorry
um
right thank you very much uh
mr chairman david um it's quite a task
to to react to all the points uh raised
but i'll do my best
indeed just to to recall um the initial
comment of of commissioner vargali
the decisions taken first by the
commission
um and then uh by the european council
are truly historic there is absolutely
no exaggeration in in that
and if we look
uh in hindsight uh
how far we have come it's it's actually
quite quite amazing um
focus is rightly on the candidate status
uh
granted to ukraine and moldova and one
that is possible for for georgia but in
fact all the three countries
um have the european perspective
confirmed for the first time ever
something which was quite difficult to
imagine
a few months ago uh we all remember that
the countries in the western balkans
were granted the european perspective at
the thessaloniki summit in june 1990
the 2003 so it's quite a while a while
ago and now it happened with regard to
the three applicants
from uh
from from the east
um um we uh
have done everything by the book i just
want to reassure uh all participants so
uh we applied the enlargement
methodology as revised in 2020
to the three applicant countries without
any shortcuts we did
things very quickly and so did they they
replied to
the membership questioners in record
time giving us a wealth of information
of very high quality which enabled us to
process
the membership applications and and be
ready uh ready in time the
analysis is rock solid and i have to say
that that it was quite
rewarding
certainly for president von de line who
was in the room to listen to the heads
of state and government praising the
commission for the quality of our
assessment that was very well balanced
and enable the council to take uh take
the decision
that it
that it took and this will continue so
the
the copenhagen criteria uh are exactly
as they were formulated in 1993
and the european council confirmed it
also putting
emphasis on the eu's own absorption
absorption capacity
of course we will have to
assess
the
the fulfillment of the steps identified
by the commission in our our opinions
uh as and as
we were we were
asked by the european council we will do
it as part of our uh regular
enlargement report so we are going to to
work on one for this year but this we
will cover
uh the balkans within broken countries
and and turkey
um
and then we'll start
on the next edition i mean it's a it's
an annual annual exercise and we draw on
the all the usual sources of uh of
information uh including member states
views i'm jumping ahead to answer one of
the questions raised of course we do
cooperate with member states and in the
end they have the final say
in their uh in the assessment of the
fulfillment of any uh criteria that are
necessary to to be fulfilled
by
candidates or potential
candidates
[Music]
many of you have spoken about georgia
and indeed our assessment show that
that georgia was not there yet
because of a number of reasons one of
them being the political polarization in
the country but i think that the
conditions identified
are reachable
and if there's enough political will
georgia can certainly
catch up and this principle of catching
up
and and
and a common um
level playing field has applied to the
countries in the western balkans so far
and we want to we will not will do the
same with the three
uh with the three applicants from uh
from the east
um
our commitment to the western balkans
and the enlargement of the western
balkans is rock solid there's no changes
and commissioner was very clear on what
we would like to achieve
we are still hoping that
that
will be able to
reach a decision on opening accession
negotiations with north macedonia and
albania
in in
in the coming days really
and this has been long overdue and i
think we are we are pretty
uh pretty close um
and we will continue working on serbia's
alignment with the common foreign
security policy
we have been given a specific task on
bosnia many of you have raised the issue
of bosnia-herzegovina there was quite
some discussion at the european council
i have to i have to admit
um and the council conclusions are uh
are clear so we
uh
we are going to um report on the
implementation of the 14 key priorities
identified in 2019
set out in in commission's opinion um
trying to to assess whether whether a
substantial set of reforms have been
uh implemented in order for the european
council to be able to take a decision on
the candidate
status for um
for for bosnia
and in kosovo and the visa
liberalization here our position has not
changed indeed
we concluded the assessment we
think that um that the decision on the
uh on on lifting i mean on introducing
the visual liberalization can be taken
now um and we have to revert to the
issue as a matter of
priority because
this decision has been long
overdue
coming to some of the specific points
raised by
members of the european parliament and
national parliaments
ukraine needs assessment indeed
we apply the cut of date in our work on
the opinion of last december
and now we are moving on uh with our
reconstruction plan for ukraine
and uh we already started working with
the world bank
on the on the needs assessment of course
it cannot be final as long as the war is
ongoing unfortunately because
destruction is still happening
every day
but we will
we will do as much as we can and then
set up um as announced in the
communication
by the european commission at the end of
my uh ukraine reconstruction platform
that we would co-lead and co-manage
european commission with the ukrainian
government
ensuring full ownership and a close link
between reconstruction and the reform
process on ukraine's
european
path
on the question of the impact of uh
the enlargement of the the uh extension
of illusion policies to the three
countries on the
uh policy instruments that we uh manage
in the commission it's not automatic
um the both regulations concerning the
ipa instrument for the accession
countries and the ici
um are our legal texts so they would
require certain amendments but for the
time being we can we can continue
working with ukraine moldova and georgia
using the ndici instrument as it is
and uh in the communication that i
mentioned before uh the commission
announced our intention to set up a
specific
uh ukraine reconstruction facility for
the future that would be the main tool
to work on both reconstruction and and
the necessary reforms
in conclusion um i
i see clearly that enlargement uh that
there is a certain revival of
enlargement policy and it will remain on
the agenda of eu leaders for quite some
time
and of course the commission will
continue playing its institutional role
as a driver of the uh enlargement policy
thank you very much for your attention
thank you
mache popovsky
if there are no further requests to take
the floor
then
[Music]
this concludes today's
inter-parliamentary meeting i would like
to thank all colleagues those connected
remotely from the national parliaments
for their participation and insightful
contributions on the future direction of
enlargement policy and also to our
colleagues here in the european
parliament in brussels
i guess we agree and this is how i would
sum up today's debate that the european
union and our 27 member states must
continue showing solidarity
and also a strategic vision in the
context of the brutal aggression against
ukraine
this is a war against the very
principles on values on which the eu is
based and therefore
i call on the decision makers across
europe to strengthen a joint commitment
to a merit-based enlargement process
responding to the legitimate aspirations
of the people to live in a free
democratic
and prosperous european family
and to result nemet
and all other national colleagues let me
once again underline what i mentioned
i sincerely hope
that this
was our last meeting in an online format
and that for the next meeting i will be
able to welcome you all
here in brussels brussels
for an inter-parliamentary committee
meeting so once again thank you for your
participation dear colleagues
and i can now
close
this point on our agenda
and i would like to inform
the affect colleagues but
i would really like to now start with
the next
item on our agenda
but for that
our rapporteur mr
pizzula would have to be present
has mr pizzula already been informed by
the secretariat
okay then i would suggest that we
wait until mr pizzula has arrived here
in the
meeting room
so we'll have a break for a couple of
minutes
okay
hello
hello this is danita speaking did you
send a message
to get through to you hello anybody
there
all
okay
hello
is anybody there
so colleagues we can continue today's
meeting
we now move on to item number four the
consideration of a draft effort
recommendation on the new eu strategy
for enlargement which follows this
year's cycle of individual enlargement
reports
in this overarching recommendation
parliament will set strategic
orientations on the future of our
enlargement policy
this debate follows last week's historic
decision to grant candidate status to
ukraine and moldova and the european
perspective to georgia which we just
have intensively discussed with
parliamentarians from
all over europe
regrettably
and i want to underline this once again
no breakthrough on opening of membership
negotiations with north macedonia and
with albania has been achieved
as we enter the 124th day of russia's
war of aggression against ukraine we
must critically reassess the way we
conduct enlargement policy
and consider the broader geopolitical
implications
it is clear that we need to face up our
joint responsibility towards ukraine
however we mustn't
neglect the western balkans and deliver
on our promises to the region redoubling
reform efforts in order to prepare for
the european union accession
the eu must put in place sustainable
conditions for welcoming new members of
the union
colleagues i will now give the floor to
tonino pizzler to present his draft
recommendations on exactly this matter
to nine of the floors yours for five
minutes
thank you david thank you chair dear
colleagues
thank you for the opportunity to present
today's draft recommendations
of this committee and this house on the
new enlargement strategy
thank you also for entrusting me with
this important task at the time of an
enlargement becomes
geopolitically strategic policy after
several years of fatigue
russian aggression on ukraine had a
tectonic impact on many of our policies
i believe we all agree that a new
impetus is needed to re-energize
enlargement process
ensuring its continuity consistency
credibility and impact
we follow the council debate and
conclusions last week the agreement on
the candidacy status for ukraine and
moldova and the recognition of the
european perspective for georgia
as a welcomed strong political sign of
support
with this decision
the scope of the enlargement policy
officially extended to the eastern
partnership countries
and our eternal administrative
structures and external financial
instruments
accordingly in the context of the before
mentioned conclusions and reactions from
the western balkan i wish to highlight
one of the main messages of the draft
text
each enlargement country should be
judged on its own merits
one of our main goals should be to
overcome enlargement gridlock by
revamping the accession process as a
political goal and in terms of its
methodology
we need to accelerate integration of the
countries that demonstrate strategic
orientation
and unwavering commitment to eu-related
reforms
democratic consolidation and foreign
policy alignment
in practice
that also means offering
membership-oriented roadmaps of tangible
and concrete steps to all aspiring
countries by further enhancing revised
enlargement methodology
furthermore we should establish clear
transparent and consistent performance
benchmarks improve progress measuring
and ensure continuing political and
technical support throughout the
accession process
the rule of law should be at the center
of the process
prioritizing jedical independence fight
against corruption and organized crime
good governance human rights fundamental
freedoms and media freedoms
we should strategically apply targeted
conditionality based on clear progress
benchmarks
rewarding reforms sanctioning regression
or a persistent lack of progress
in the same context we must put greater
emphasis on the alignment on accession
countries with the eu's common foreign
and security policy
in practice that would mean stepping up
solidarity and entering political and
economic incentives for accession
countries
ensuring that intermediate integration
steps do not substitute but facilitate
the final goal of a fully fledged eu
membership
and my final remark would be urgent need
to recognize western balkan's country's
achievements by opening long overdue
accession talks with northern macedonia
and albania and granting visa
liberalization to kosovo without delay
european strategic relevance and
credibility depend on this decision
and we must not
keep missing on confirming our
geopolitical ambitions in press practice
the people of all but one countries
support the eu accession by delivering
on our commitments and showing political
leadership we must make them and our
citizens believe that eu can deliver on
its historic mission this house was
always the most prominent supporter of
enlargement with our joint work and by
adapting solid recommendations on how
the future enlargement policy should be
implemented we can once again set the
tone and standards to enable the union
to grow and prosper
we wish to ensure that the eu remains an
evolving community of european states
open to the accession of like-minded
democracies sharing common values and
interest
looking forward to your comments
remarks and our future joint work on
this document i would like to thank you
for your attention
thank you to nino for presenting us your
draft i will now give the floor to the
shadow raptors or their replacements and
the first one is our colleague andreas
cabellos
well uh first of all uh thanks a lot and
of course
i would praise uh what nino pizzula
presented as a first draft report of
course we shall come with some
additional amendments
but
definitely is a very important topic and
it's good that you know there is an
initiative to draft
such kind of report exactly at this time
one i hope that enlargement policy is
coming back you know to
be understood first of all inside of
european union as a most important
geopolitical policy of eu and that you
know this policy will become again
ambitious and
and effective
so uh as a title new eu strategy for
enlargement should not uh
lead us to some kind of you know
misunderstanding
i would see it as the same enlargement
strategy but with reinvented its
transformative power
and here i would say you know that even
in
[Music]
last you know
several decades of our experience we
could see two types of enlargement
policy of the same european union
there was big bank of 10 countries with
croatia you know
following
with
dynamic transformative process you know
which really brought a lot of
you know uh
positive outcomes both for applicant
countries and for you itself and then
came western balkans you know uh in la
processing to western enlargement into
western balkans
which unfortunately you know because of
different reasons
is showing some kind of outcome of
imperson
lost trust into enlargement the
motivation for reforms in african
countries and definitely lost
transformative power so in my
from my point of view what it would be
good for us
really while we understand that you know
uh enlargement policies becoming again
very important your political policy we
should start looking into you know
lessons learned exercise
what was wrong what you know where were
our mistakes why you know really we had
this difference of western balkans if
you compare with big bang and there are
no perhaps several reasons you know
including that some countries wanted to
wait for
institutional reforms then you know here
here became you know very popular to try
to settle
you know your own historical
pains with the neighboring countries so
now and so on and so on so let's start
from lessons land and then let's look
how really to avoid those mistakes uh
looking into the future and how to make
really again our
enlargement strategy ambitious result
orientated and really bringing outcomes
during the next decade both for western
balkans and for ukraine moldova and
georgia thanks a lot
thank you andrews kubilias for the renew
touch and charlotte please
thank you chair
i also would like to thank to mr pizzula
for this good
first
draft
report
it's a subject uh hiked of the on the
agenda and
i think beyond the specific subject we
have to be aware that
in order to have a successful
new strategy for enlargement we have to
take into account some institutional
changes
internally in european union but this is
not the subject of today
i am
happy with a lot of ideas proposed by mr
pisola in the in the report and i
supporting that i will
come with some
amendments in order to improving uh to
improve the the clarity
related to the rule of law and
independence of the justice
this has already been decided as i know
as part of the
consensus enlargement in 2006 but i also
think we need to put this at the center
of the process uh now taking into
account also the
advances that we registered in for the
member states with the new mechanism for
rule of law and i think we have to find
a way to use
rule of law and independence of justice
not only as a permission for the
candidate countries but also as an
incentive to have access to some eu uh
policies in order in order to encourage
them politically to do these uh hard
reforms
uh for the problem of bilateral disputes
uh that is something blocking the
accession process and this is rightly
stressed in the in the report my
proposal would be to encourage probably
the council
to come with an official mechanism of
arbitration
we
have seen
some initiative of the president of the
council but i think we need something
more now
learning also from the lessons of the
of the past on the institutional side
uh
i think we have to find a way to involve
more national parliaments in the process
in order to have also the member states
on board because i expect that
to advance with enlargement we will need
to convince a lot of member states and
if
not only the governments involved in the
negotiation but also the parliament will
be involved
this will be helpful for the process
and i also think uh as an incentive we
have to find a way to have
colleagues from the candidate countries
as observer in european parliament at
the earlier
stage
then on
strengthening political pluralist
political dialogue or civil uh society
i think we have to
be sure that we'll have funds needed to
be allocated
via epa or other financial instruments
for that
and
also to
ensure a lot longer transitional process
for this financing because we know that
this
process of uh strengthening uh
democratic transformation process are
never over and especially reinforcing
civil society we can see how important
how important this
is
and finally a very important
subject and structural one
for me is that
we have to come with a proposal for a
pro integrative
uh
phasing in integrative uh process
uh
and one of the idea would be that once
we close the negotiations
of a cluster we have also institutional
institutions in uh in place and
legislation uh transferred to give
access to the candidate countries to eu
policies at the earlier
stage i have seen something from mr
pizzula putting in a report and i would
like to
go deepening uh this idea thank you
thank you for the greens tinicus streak
thank you thank you chair thank you very
much roberto mr bitula sorry for being a
bit late but i heard your presentation
nevertheless
and thanks a lot for the draft that you
put forward
i think in all in all we can
we can
support your direction but we will
nevertheless come up with some
amendments to improve uh the text
we very much underline also your
approach that it should be your merits
based process the accession and
enlargement but also that we need to
actively support the countries in order
to meet those criteria that we that the
eu
puts forward and that we also should be
credible and consistent in applying
these criteria and and what we just also
saw of course with northern macedonia
and albania um there is this lack of of
consistency which create a huge
huge disappointment in the whole western
balkan countries and and we really need
to take that very seriously because we
need the trust and credibility in order
to keep them engaged to to reform
the things
um and therefore we also very much agree
with your proposal to have those in
between steps
not
decided by unanimity but by qualified
majority so that we cannot
have this whole enlargement process in
every step you know being hostage by
bilateral disputes or national interests
we very much agree with um the urgent
call for visa liberalization for kosovo
and uh regarding uh bosnia-herzegovina
we would
like to emphasize uh strongly also that
we need to grant them candidate
membership
if some
in in our view very doable conditions
are being met at a short term for
instance those laws that are still on
the table in the republic of subscribe
that they are removed
that all political leaders returned to
their institutions to to let the country
function again
but also that the process of
constitutional reforms will be resumed
after free and fair elections in a more
inclusive process where also civil
society and all political parties are
involved
really based on the correct
implementation of the european and human
rights judgments
without
allowing any type of discrimination
between citizens and this would be the
real genuine
implementation of the case law of the
european court of human rights and i
think we need to be
specifically critical on the the
proposals on the table for the electoral
law in that regard
furthermore we very much support also
the emphasis on rule of law performances
and also that we should be consistent no
matter which status a country he has
even if it's already uh has accessed the
eu then still we need to have a rigid
and consistent application of our
standards and also enforce it and and be
willing to use all the instruments
available and furthermore we support
indeed to to use the money for for those
rule of law and anti-corruption uh
criteria and
yeah all in all i think it's very clear
that we are supportive
uh but that would should not stick with
granting candidates stated but it comes
along also with commitment and
engagement with the countries not only
with the political leaders but also with
civil society and all actors in those
countries thank you
thank you tineke
for the id group jerry mariani is the
shadow rapporteur
but he's not
present
for the ecr
mr jambotsky is rapperter
he is also not present
and for the left idoya villanueva ruiz
is the shadow
she is also not present
from colleagues in the plenary i would
like to first get the floor to michiel
gala
thank you very much i think
indeed and
we should use the momentum now and i
therefore i thank to nino for his for
his draft and we have already heard
uh
also some additional uh creative ideas i
particularly liked what was said
uh by the colleague uh concerning uh
observable
observation status for for
uh for colleagues from these parliaments
i mean we had it i recall
in 2004 we started in 2003 but only when
the negotiations had finished and then
colleagues from this parliament got an
observer status
perhaps indeed we could uh
and bring that forward uh to to involve
colleagues from countries concerned
earlier in in our deliberations here um
moreover i am definitely i feel con
confirmed my opinion that i had in
earlier phases
not to have package deals
uh
so to pack
two or several countries together and
then make the one dependent on the fate
of the other one
i think in the given situation with
albania and north macedonia
i would wish that for the future and
perhaps even in this process if we
cannot solve the macedonia bulgarian
issue that we might
liberate
albania out of this
package and and get the start with with
them
i think also
when we discuss this momentum we must
insist that
uh what we did not have unfortunately in
the european council
conclusions that we must insist as a
parliament to have in parallel uh the uh
a new
convent convention uh that was this
article 48 demand from the parliament
was in our resolution but we didn't find
it in
in the uh
uh european council conclusions to the
contrary what i hear is that
there is a really little appetite
to address
potential treaty changes which is of
course necessary
to do and i think we should
continue to insist in parallel because
uh if this argument is there we cannot
enlarge because we cannot change
there is a little hope to change then we
must at least give it a try and and see
perhaps that we start with the pastoral
clauses that exist and and check whether
something could be done there and
perhaps one other idea i heard it from
ukraine although not officially but from
colleagues
they suggested if
the unanimity in some policy areas
if that is a point
that is as an argument not to enlarge
because we cannot allow more vetoes
to to live with in future than they said
or there were people who said okay we
could formally abandon this right and
say okay we come in but are not
insisting to exercise our veto right
and that could perhaps even serve as a
good example for even for member states
not only for candidates who say in order
to get us moving and to take
take things forward why can individual
member states not unilaterally
abandon their veto right and thereby if
it is many
exercise such an extent of pressure on
the others to abandon it as well that
that is perhaps the way to proceed these
are some thoughts that
i have in this regard perhaps i'm coming
up with some amendments also thank you
thank you i have one more request to
take the floor
nacho sanchez some more bernard getter
okay
these two and then i'll close the
speaking list not sure
thank you very much david i think that
the key word tonino has used is
credibility
we have shown credibility as part of the
european union in the last few years in
the brexit crisis in the resilient funds
in the fight against covet 19 but we
have a lack of credibility in the
enlargement and i like tonina's document
because it's a classical document
there is no experiment we know the
meaning of the enlargement process
and i really like the fact that tonino
is using this classical framework
because we are
expressing too many enlargement
strategies
many of those strategies are overlapped
so this means that we have no clear
strategy every 15 days
a leader of a country launches a new
model and that
negotiation model is basically an excuse
for inaction
and now another topic
the democratic
conditionality is related to the
political will of the country
sometimes it seems that the european
union has the moral obligation of
turning a country into a democracy
that's based
on the will of the institutions and the
political leaders and we cannot be
substitutes i have a personal experience
of the process in spain spain wanted to
be a democracy a mature democracy
and
it wasn't related to the incentives from
europe sometimes we are changing the
process and some countries ask us for
incentives i understand incentives to
change the economic system or for
example to change the administration but
in order to be a real
much worse democracy
not to
fight against freedom of press we have
no incentives for that and i think that
the
political will is an essential element
that has to be shown by the countries
and it cannot be forced from brussels
and i think we should always take that
into account thank you very much
thank you ben i get him
we
it seems to me that in the historical
times we're going through we come under
three
different obligations the first one is
to enlarge of course
to those countries that are threatened
by the
military russian aggression but also
obviously
to the balkan countries secondly
[Music]
it's the obligation is not to let these
many
this
vast enlargement and countries
we can't let that paralyze european
institutions and third we must go fast
we can't continue to
disappoint those countries that have
been candidates or are going to become
candidates by making them wait for 10 15
20 or 25 years so the conclusion is very
simple
we must
advance fast and
undertake to
rethink and reinvent our european
institutions which would
finally allow us to
meet these three
obligations
otherwise
let's not delude ourselves there will
not be any
enlargement not any real
enlargement in the medium term but only
in the long term very long term
so if we are bold and brave
if we want to walk the talk and not lie
to
candidates not disappoint them
and offer them to other powers than us
who are waiting by and
praying on their
disappointment we must proceed to reform
institutions and the parliament should
be the driving force within the union
thank you
right
thank you no further requests to take
the floor i will now hand over to the
representatives of the genera and the
eas
mr thomas hackletner and miss elsa
fennette are both here so the floor is
yours for each three minutes peterson
thank you very much uh chair and thank
you very much mr pizzula for this uh
report
and for the support you put to the
eu's enlargement policy and in
particular the
own merits principle that you have
highlighted
i think you've all
mentioned that enlargement is back high
up on the agenda we've seen it last week
where the european council endorsed the